[Music]
while preparations were going on for our
march into the interior
numerous consultations were held with
cortes we
his trustworthy adherents proposed that
all the vessels should be run
on shore in order at once to cut off all
possibility of further mutiny
this resolution was immediately adopted
after the vessels had been run ashore
before our eyes and we the officers and
soldiers were one morning after marcel
standing around cortes
the discourse turned upon various
military topics
when he begged our attention for a few
minutes as he had some proposal to make
to us we already know of the campaign
which was in contemplation
it was of such a nature that the aid of
jesus christ
our lord only could bring us forth
victorious from all the battles and
engagements which awaited us
but notwithstanding all the trust we put
in god
we should not ourselves be wanting in
courage
cortes then induced many beautiful
comparisons from history
and mentioned several heroic deeds of
the romans
we answered him one and all that we
would implicitly follow his orders
as the die had been cast and we with
caesar
when he had passed the rubicon had now
no choice left
the road along which we marched was
eight paces in breath
and if i still remember ran in a
perfectly straight line
to mexico notwithstanding the breadth
it was much too narrow to hold the vast
crowds of people who continually kept
arriving from different parts to gaze
upon us
besides this the tops of all the temples
and towers were crowded
while the lake beneath was completely
covered with canoes
filled with indians for all were curious
to catch a glimpse of us
and who can wander at this as neither
men like unto ourselves
nor horses had ever been seen here
before when we gazed upon all this
splendor at once
we scarcely knew what to think and we
doubted whether all that we beheld
was real a series of large towns
stretched themselves along the banks of
the lake out of which still larger ones
rose magnificently above the waters
innumerable crowds of canoes were plying
everywhere around us
at regular distances we continually
passed over new bridges
and before us lay the great city
of mexico in all its splendor
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
here at voices of the past we provide
you with the raw source without context
and magellan is a great choice if you
want to know more
they have more than 3 thousand
documentaries that pair well with our
videos
a good example to accompany this video
is pocahontas and john
smith which explores the truth behind
the legends hidden in both the oral and
written accounts
which can contradict one another and
whether it's 16th century america or
first century rome
magellan is the place to go to find out
more in an entertaining way
and you can now take advantage of an
exclusive offer 30 percent off an annual
membership
that gives you an entire year for less
than 3.50 a month
even if you've joined magellan before
and lapsed you can simply click on the
link in the description
to claim your discounted membership
today thanks
and we who were gazing upon all this
passing through innumerable crowds of
human beings
were a mere handful of men in all
450 i may safely ask the kind reader to
ponder a moment
and say whether he thinks any men in the
world ever ventured so bold a stroke as
this
when we had arrived at a place not far
from the town where several small towers
rose together
montez zuma raised himself in his sedan
and the chiefs supported him under the
arms and held over his head
a canopy of exceedingly great value
montezuma himself
according to his custom was sumptuously
attired
had on a species of half boot richly set
with jewels
and whose souls were made of solid gold
no one of his sweet
ever looked at him full in the face
everyone in his presence
stood with eyes down cast while others
again
occupied the road before him and spread
cotton cloths on the ground
that his feet might not touch the bare
earth
when it was announced to cortez that
montezuma himself was approaching
he alighted from his horse and advanced
to meet him
many compliments were now passed on both
sides if i still remember rightly
cortes wished to concede the place of
honor to the monarch
who however would not accept it the road
before us now became less crowded
and yet who would have been able to
count the vast numbers of men
women and children who filled the
streets crowded the balconies
and the canoes and the canals merely to
gaze upon us
indeed at the moment i am writing this
everything comes as lively to my eyes as
if it had happened yesterday
indeed i cannot sufficiently praise
jesus christ
that i have been allowed to live thus
long to narrate these adventures
although they may not turn out as
perfect as i myself
could wish
[Music]
we allotted the apartments according to
the several companies
placed our cannon in an advantageous
position and made such arrangements that
our cavalry
as well as the infantry might be ready
at a moment's notice
after montezuma had dined and was
likewise informed that we had left
table he set out from his palace in
great pomp
accompanied by a number of his grandes
and all his relations
to pay us a visit montezuma then began a
very excellent discourse
and first of all expressed his delight
to entertain in his kingdom and city
such courageous cavaliers as cortes
and all of us were a couple of years ago
he had received intelligence that some
other officer had made his appearance at
the province of champaton
and a year later of a second who had
been off the coast with four vessels
he had long desired to see cortes and
since his wishes were now fulfilled
he was ready to render us any service
and provide us with everything we might
require
he was now convinced that we were those
people of whom his earliest forefathers
had spoken
a people that would come from the rising
of the sun and conquer these countries
all further doubt had vanished from his
mind
to which cortes answered that we should
never be able to repay him
for all the kindness he had shown us we
indeed
came from the rising of the sun and were
servants and subjects of a powerful
monarch
called don carlos who had numerous
distinguished princes among his vassals
and had expressly sent us to his country
to beg of him
and his subjects to become converts to
the christian faith
for the salvation of their souls in this
way
a pleasant discourse was kept up between
montezuma
and cortes
our general now issued strict commands
that no one should stir from
headquarters
until we had gained some certain
knowledge as to how matters
really stood
more than 300 kinds of dishes were
served up for montezuma's dinner from
his kitchen
underneath which were placed pans of
porcelain
filled with fire to keep them warm 300
dishes of various kinds were served up
for him alone
and above a thousand for the persons in
waiting
we were told that the flesh of young
children as a very dainty bit
was also set before him sometimes by way
of a relish
whether there was any truth in this we
could not possibly discover
on account of the great variety of
dishes consisting in fowls
turkeys pheasants partridges quails tame
and wild geese
venison musk swine pigeons hares rabbits
and of numerous other birds and beasts
indeed it would have been no easy task
to call them all by their name
this i know however for certain that
after cortez had reproached him for the
human sacrifices and the eating
of human flesh he issued orders that no
dishes of that nature
should again be brought to his table
respecting the
abominable human sacrifices of these
people
the following was communicated to us the
breast of the
unhappy victim destined to be sacrificed
was ripped open with a knife made of
sharp flint
the throbbing heart was then torn out
and immediately offered to the idol god
in whose honour the sacrifice had been
made after this
the head arms and legs were cut off and
eaten at their banquets
with the exception of the head which was
saved and hung
to a beam appropriated for that purpose
no other part of the body was eaten
but the remainder was thrown to the
beasts where there are also
vipers and other poisonous serpents and
among the latter in particular
a species at the end of whose tale there
was a kind of
rattle we were positively told that
after we had been beaten out of the city
of mexico and had lost 850 of our men
these horrible beasts were fed for many
successive days
with the bodies of our unfortunate
countrymen
sometimes during dinner time montezuma
would have ugly indian humpback dwarfs
who acted as buffoons and performed
antics for his amusement
at another time he would have gestures
to enliven him with their witticisms
montezuma took great delight in these
entertainments
indeed the daily expense of these
dinners alone
must have been very great they then
presented him with three
beautifully painted and gilt tubes which
were filled with
liquid amber and a herb cooled by the
indians
tobacco and the monarch took the smoke
into his mouth
and after he had done this a short time
he fell asleep
cortes now determined to view the city
and visit the great market and the chief
temple
of witsi lapochte on our proceeding to
the great temple
and passing the courtyards adjoining the
market we observed numbers of other
merchants
who dealt in gold dust as it was dug out
of the mines
which was exposed to sail in tubes made
of the bones of large geese
which had been worked to such a thin
substance and was so white
that the gold shone through them the
value of these
tubes of gold was estimated according to
their length
and thickness before we mounted the
steps of the great temple
montezuma who was sacrificing on the top
to his idols
sent six papas and two of his principal
officers
to conduct cortes up the steps there
were 114 steps to the summit
and as they feared that cortes would
experience the same fatigue and mounting
that montezuma had
they were going to assist him by taking
hold of his arms
cordes however will not accept of their
aid
when we had reached the summit of the
temple we walked across a platform
where many large stones were lying on
which those were doomed for sacrifice
were stretched out near these stood a
large
idol in the shape of a dragon surrounded
by various other
abominable figures with a quantity of
fresh blood
lying in front of it montezuma himself
stepped out of a chapel in which his
cursed gods were standing
and received cortes and the whole of us
very courteously
ascending this temple said he to our
commander
must certainly have fatigued you cortes
however assured him
through our interpreters that it was not
possible for anything
to tire us upon this the monarch took
hold of his hand
and invited him to look down and view
his vast metropolis
with the towns which were built in the
lake and the other towns
which surrounded the city indeed this
infernal temple
from its great height commanded a view
of the whole surrounding neighborhood
we observed the aqueduct which provided
the whole town with sweet water
the lake itself was crowded with canoes
which were bringing provisions
manufacturers
and other merchandise to the city in all
these towns the beautiful white
plastered temples rose above
the smaller ones like so many towers and
castles in our spanish towns
and this it may be imagined was a
splendid sight
after we had sufficiently gazed upon
this magnificent picture
we again turned our eyes towards the
great market
and beheld the vast numbers of buyers
and sellers who thronged there
some of our men who had been at
constantinople and rome
and travelled through the whole of italy
said that they had never seen a
marketplace of such large dimensions
or which was so well regulated or so
crowded with people
as this one but mexico
next to this temple was another one in
which humans skulls and bones were piled
up
though both apart their numbers were
endless
this place had also its appropriate
idols and in all these temples we found
priests clad in
long black mantles with hoods shaped
like those worn by the dominican friars
their ears were pierced and the hair of
their head
was long and stuck together with
coagulated blood
cortez and the whole of us at last grew
tired of the sight of so many idols and
implements used for these sacrifices and
we returned to our quarters
accompanied by a great number of chief
personages whom montezuma had sent for
that purpose
[Music]
our general and father almeido readily
perceived that montezuma would never
give his consent
to our erecting across on his chief
temple
nor that we should build a chapel there
but in three days our church was
finished
and a cross planted in front of our
quarters as all of us
officers as well as privates were men of
experience full of energy and very
determined
who had never lost sight that the lord
jesus christ had assisted us with his
divine hand in all our undertakings we
deputed four officers and twelve of our
most trustworthy and faithful soldiers
myself being among the number to cortes
and represented to him how we were
cooped up in this strong city
as if we had been caught in a net or a
cage
taking all this into consideration our
opinion was
that we had no other resource left by
which we could place our own lives in
safety
than by seizing the monarch's person
without delay
cortes in reply to their representation
said
do not imagine gentlemen that i either
sleep so peaceably
or that what you have just been stating
has not caused me much anxiety
but we all first to weigh well whether
you think we are sufficiently strong in
numbers for so bold and attempt as to
take this mighty monarch prisoner
in his own palace one hour was thus
spent into liberating as to whether we
should take him or to zoom a prisoner
and the manner in which it was to be
done at last we came to the resolution
of seizing the monarch's person on the
following day
and cortes gave his full consent
after we had come to the determination
of seizing the person of montezuma
and had been on our knees the whole
night in prayer we made the necessary
arrangements
when mourning came for that purpose
everyone received orders to be ready to
march out at a moment's notice
and the horses were to be kept saddled
our general
now sallied forth accompanied by our
five chief
officers
after cortez had entered his apartment
and the usual compliments had been
passed
he thus addressed montezuma i'm greatly
astonished that the prince of such power
who styles himself our friend should
have commanded his
troops which lie on the coast near
tuzapan to take up arms against my
spanish troops
and presume to demand a certain number
of men and women for the sacrifices
from those townships but this is not all
they have plundered those places and
even killed one of my brothers
and a horse how very differently we
acted on our side continued cordes
i had put reliance in your friendship
and desired my officers in every way to
comply with your wishes
you on the contrary have commanded your
officers the very opposite
at the present moment your generals have
the audacity to plot in secret to put us
all to death
however notwithstanding all this
treachery
i will refrain from making war upon you
which would only end in the total
destruction
of this city but in order that peace may
be maintained between us
you must make a small sacrifice which is
to follow us quietly into our quarters
and take up your abode there but if you
make any alarm now
or call out to your attendance you are a
dead man
montezuma was seized with such a sudden
terror at these words
that he remained speechless for some
time at length however
he took courage and declared he had
never given any orders to take up arms
against
us he would that instant sent for his
generals and learn from them the truth
of the whole matter
cortes in answer to this gave him very
good reasons for our having come to this
determination but montezuma continually
brought in stronger reasons why he
should not comply
he said to cortes since you repose no
trust in me
take my son and my daughters as hostages
only do not disgrace me by demanding my
person what will the grandees of my
empire say
if they see me taken prisoner cordes
however
said that his own person would be the
only guarantee of our safety
and that there were no other means of
quieting our fears
at last montezuma after a good deal of
altercation
made up his mind to go quietly with us
his rich and splendid sedan was then
brought in which he commonly used when
he left his palace with his whole suite
and he followed us to our quarters where
we took every precaution
to secure his person
shortly afterwards all the mexican
grandes with his nephew called upon him
to inquire the reason of his
imprisonment
and ask him if they should commence
hostilities against us
but montezuma told them he wished to do
himself the pleasure of passing a few
days with us
and that this change of abode was of his
own
free choice and these are the true
circumstances
relative to the imprisonment of
montezuma he was always surrounded by
the whole of his household
and had all his wives with him and
continued to bathe himself daily as he
had been accustomed to
after some time it elapsed the generals
who had fought against escalante
were brought in prisoners to the monarch
what he told them on that occasion i do
not know
but he sent them to cortes to pronounce
judgement on them
himself our generals made no further
ceremony with these mexicans
but sentenced them to death and they
were burnt alive
in front of montezuma's palace
and that no impediment might be thrown
in the way while these sentences were
being put to execution
cortes ordered chains to be put on
montezuma at first he certainly did not
approve of this
but in the end he quietly submitted and
grew even more
tractable afterwards when the executions
had taken place
cortes approached him with five of our
officers and himself
took off his chains again with the
assurance
that he loved him more than a brother
the severe example which cortes had made
of the mexican generals had its full
effect
the news thereof ran like wildfire
throughout the whole of new spain
the tribes along the coast by whom our
troops of veracruz had been defeated
were seized with terror and again
offered their services to the garrison
there
sometimes also montezuma played at a
certain game with cortes
which the mexicans call the game of
totterlock
it is played with small round glossy
balls
which here were made of gold and are
pitched at a certain mark
also of the same metal five throws
finished the game
and the stakes were four valuable gold
trinkets and jewels
i still remember once when montezuma and
cortes were playing at this game
alvarado scoring for cortes and a
distinguished chief for the monarch
that alvarado continually scored one too
many for cortes
this was observed by montezuma who said
with a pleasing smile
that he was not exactly pleased when
tornadio
so they termed alvarado mark the game
for cortes
i must now beg the kind reader to pause
a moment
upon the heroic deeds we performed and
consider
their magnitude first of all we destroy
all our vessels and thereby cut off all
hopes of escaping from this country
we then venture to march into this
strong city though we were warned
against it on all sides
we then have the audacity to imprison
the monarch of this vast empire
the powerful montezuma in his own
metropolis
and at last we even fearlessly burn some
of his generals to death
in front of his own palace and throw the
monarch himself in chains while this is
being executed
even now in my old age the heroic deeds
we then accomplished
come vividly to my memory but must also
acknowledge that although we had our
hands full
we were aided by divine providence
these things indeed ought to be deeply
pondered on
and not mentioned so briefly as i here
have done
[Music]
you